hi everyone and my name is Tamara
chambers and this is Tamara's never seen
and today is the first video of Tam
tober fest and I'm very excited about it
and it might just not sound excited
about it right this very second because
I already filmed this video and the
microphone didn't work and it's fine
it's not a big deal I'm not very angry
about it today I'm watching Casper I was
talking to some friends about it and
they were like oh my god you're gonna
have literally the best time with that
movie you're gonna have such a crush on
something got Devin charlie Carroll I
forgot his name already did this once
today huh and then I went and worked out
so my hair is disgusting and sweaty and
here we are I'm not mad about it at all
let's get to it
towba first not so fast little man the
bitch is back me I'm sorry I didn't mean
to yell at you don't leave I had an
unexpectedly good time with this movie
and the only thing that really took away
from me was I just didn't like Casper
the Friendly Ghost more like the creepy
flirtatious ghost the Friendly Ghost
more like I don't want you to keep me
ghost the Friendly Ghost more like I
just didn't have a third one so the
Trident your Wonder Woman sword a bit
hilarious every time there were a few
plot holes but that's to be expected you
know for sure I'll be clear also that I
didn't hate Casper I just found some
very creepy in some individual moments
the level of flirtatious sexual energy
that he was putting out was astounding
for a twelve-year-old
and not in a good way the whole thing is
really the Casper wants a friend and
always scares these friends away that
relates that very much very very much I
please stay with me time passes and the
worst character that I've ever
scene in film I think inherits the house
and she's got a little henchman dibs big
out of the house and I'm very
disappointed to see the condition it's
in mostly that it's haunted by four
ghosts so they call in an exorcist to
get rid of the ghosts and this team is
amazing and isn't that the same guy that
voices the dynamite man from Atlantis is
it or is it not
I wrote oh my God my favorite
Ghostbusters appearance ever amazing so
Casper has scared away the new tenants
as well again he just scares him all the
way sees a small little floating sperm
and it's scary so he sees this ad on TV
for this ghost therapist and he's like
great great great he shows the evil
Cruella de Vil character what's her name
Channing Tatum chancellor jim manikan
republic i don't know you guys what her
name is so she calls oh it's gonna
bother me so much Kerrigan so Harvey
this ghost therapist and his daughter
Kat moved into the mansion she doesn't
believe in goes she's like whatever dad
as if you know very 90s then they see
Casper for the first time and they're
both super scared and the dads like I'll
protect you honey and he's about to run
off and she's like wait dad I just sorry
I didn't believe you and it's really
cute and I really enjoy their
relationship okay but the physics of
Casper let's talk let's get into some
physics sometimes Casper can go through
things and then sometimes Casper picks
up things so was it like a flex thing if
like Casper's flexing then he can like
grab it but if he's not flexing it just
going kook phases through him what is
the physics there tell me tell me tell
me cuz it's not explained at all and
that's what the kids watching Casper
really want to know then you meet the
three ghosts the uncle ghosts they're
very annoying I don't really enjoy them
into the very final 20 seconds of the
film there is one point though where
they knock the dad out and then they all
enter him
via his mouth and it's very unsettling
especially the bigger ghosts going in
the desk it looks dirty I don't know why
I don't know what it really looks like
specifically but it's specifically
pretty gross then they morph the dad's
head into other people's heads to scare
him and there's Mel Gibson and Clint
Eastwood and that skeleton from what
tales of the Crypt what is that from
where are you from sir at one point the
bigger ghost goes are we scary what do
you just say that to yourself casually
into others I don't like sit at my home
like edit a and then just randomly go am
i diabetic or what it was stupid I hated
it so Casper makes them breakfast that's
very cute wins over Harvey and cats and
there was a lot of flirtatious actions
happening but I didn't know to the
extent it was gonna go I thought maybe
one just ends there
so in catch first day of junior high
school at this brand-new school the
teacher and all of the class offer her
up and her home her creepy-ass home as
like the place where their Halloween
party is going to be thrown that's a
very big assumption I'd like to be like
no it's gonna be cool with your dad
let's just do it all right on the count
of three you're wrong in the boat
yes it's I didn't even count we're doing
it Casper really wants to be Kats date
that was my first clue like oh man I
thought he just wanted a friend he was
like if I was human would you go to the
dance with me
and then she falls asleep and then he
kisses her on the cheek is like can I
keep and it's like what rewind what was
that excuse me can I kiss he mean that
he wants to kill her and then harvest
her body for organs and then like keep
her did you want her to be a ghost in
his so you can keep her is you just want
to keep her in a cage does he just want
her to live in the mansion his whole
what huh that's such a weird line I feel
like they could have used any other line
she kind of downplayed the flirtatious
actions though she helps him find out
who he was as a kid his dad was an
inventor which is why the house is so
cool till they find this Lazarus
resurrection machine
and there's enough potion to bring back
Casper to life
I wrote down is Casper gonna come back
to life because that is not where I
thought this movie was going I thought
Casper the Friendly Ghost there's nobody
like some ghost shenanigans it's gonna
be really cute and fun and just kind of
like maybe boring in no way shape or
form did I think that Casper was going
to come back to life Carrigan steals the
potion though she was going to kill her
partner dibs but then instead she dies
because she falls off the side of a
cliff it happens to the best of us James
is like actually I'm not gonna resurrect
you instead I'm gonna take all of the
money I'm gonna buy a big house with
purple walls and green carpet and a
little dog named Carrigan a bitch just
like you and it was hilarious then
because of course the dad harvey falls
off a cliff as well too in the span of
five minutes in this movie and i feel
like maybe they could have figured out
another way for one of them to die so
they're like both didn't fall off of a
cliff but you know whatever it's the 90s
it's a wild time Casper gets back the
potion from Carrigan he remains a ghost
and he gives it to the dad here's a
question what the fuck is going on with
these other ghosts you get to know what
hatchway looks like in real life because
he comes back spoilers he looks nothing
like his ghost and then Carrigan and the
dad Harvey they look a lot like their
ghost and then the uncles they look
nothing like anything any human would
look like then Harvey's wife and cat's
mom comes back as a ghost and she's not
even an animated CGI ghost she's just a
human who's like backlit a lot so she's
like looking at cereal but mom ghost
comes back and she's like I see what you
did there
it's very noble and courageous and brave
of you so here have a few hours as a
real human boy because she has that
power for some reason never explained
why she lets him become a boy for a
couple hours so he'd go down to the
dance that's been going on in their
house now there's a Halloween dance for
seventh graders he walks up to cap he
starts dancing where there and he
whispers
beautiful so creepy and then he turns
back into a ghost and scares everyone in
the classroom and it's great but three
uncle ghosts start up a band for some
reason and sing Casper the Friendly
Ghost and then Harvey and cat and Casper
dance it should be cast for the sexual
ghost but it was still very fun you will
wonder how much dan Aykroyd was paid for
that cameo listen he just loves ghosts
he doesn't do it for the money he does
it for the ghosts
you'll be at war with yourself on one
side it's classic nineties pandering but
at the same time it actually tries out
character and emotion uh so agreed there
show me 90s cliches maybe the uncle's is
just onejust nineties cliche but I found
myself really enjoying the relationships
I love this movie so much I can't do
predictions well no matter how hard I
tried Justin that was an amazing
prediction well done love love this
movie it's one of those movies I could
literally be in the mood to watch from
start to finish at any time I think your
reaction will be similar to the Indian
in the cupboard review it's goofy but
has emotion the effects and sets are
very cool yeah it was just fun it was
cute it was surprisingly heartfelt and I
don't know I feel like how did I not
come up with this next week I am
watching one that's been on my list
forever
I was even in the NC review of it ah be
standing up Monster Squad see you soon
bad can I keep you
[Music]
[Applause]
you